okay so we just talked about
cross-validation which is an important
technique for
both regression and classification for
getting a getting idea of test error and
for assessing
um how complex a model to fit for
example how many features to include in
a model or the order of a polynomial um
and it's it's a very important technique
and sometimes with important techniques
like this it's good idea to see how how
one might do it wrong
and this is actually an error that we've
seen people a way in which people use
cross validation in a
in a wrong fashion which can have
actually very serious consequences
especially these days where you get very
wide data sets and and this next example
is going to show you such a case so
we'll go go into detail how one can do
it wrong and how people use it wrong and
we'll try to avoid that error and help
you to avoid that error so let's think
of a simple thought
thought experiment we've got 5000
predictors for example and 50 samples
this is again
a more and more commonly occurring case
where we have more predictors and
samples
and we have two classes we're trying to
predict okay
um and suppose we do the following we've
built a simple classifier in the
following way we
first of all we we filtered the
predictors find the 100 predictors
having the largest correlation on their
own with the class labels okay so we're
going to cherry pick here we pick the
top 100 predictors keep them and again
they're chosen the basis of their their
correlation with the class labels on
their own and we throw away the
remaining 4 900 predictors okay and then
we we use 100 predictors with the clock
we use them is in a classifier such as a
logic model using
only these 100 predictors and we omit
the other 4 900.
so that's not unreasonable we have
building a classifier for example maybe
we don't have to deal with 5000
predictors we just want a small number
of them
but the question we address here is how
do we get an idea of the test set error
of this classifier cross validation
okay thank you um
but how can we i mean what's tempting is
to say well let's just forget the fact
that we filtered the predictors in step
one that we chose the 100 best among the
five thousand
let's just pretend like we started in
step two that we started with the 100
predictors
and and that was our data can we apply
cross-validation in step
two forgetting about step one
well no this is a serious error
why is it an error well the problem is
is that the procedure the classifier has
already seen the labels of the trainings
of the training data
in step one right in choosing
the um the best 100 predictors it's
looked at all the labels of all the
samples right
so the predictors it have have already
used
the the full set of observations in the
fitting when we chose those predictors
so that's a form of training
and we can't ignore it in the validation
process
so the
the the point is we're not allowed to
just start in step two and ignore the
fact that we applied step one
why is that well
this is something you should try
yourself
you can simulate data with class labels
having um no correlation with the
outcome so that if the with equal
classes the true test error is 50
but cross validation the ignore step one
will give you an error rate of zero
right
so it's a serious serious bias
um cross-validation telling your
classifier is perfect when in fact your
classifier is the same as flipping a
coin
okay
and
they think about why this happens if you
if we
actually if we make the point more
clearly if we if we increase the 5 000
to maybe
5 million predictors suppose we have 5
million predictors and 50 samples and
again there's no correlation in the
population between the predictors and
the class labels
we go ahead and we pick the best 100 of
among those 5 million predictors we're
going to find some very good looking
predictors despite the fact in the
population
no predictor has correlation with the
outcome in the data if we look at the
best
among five million we're going to find
some very good predictors that look and
the data like they have a lot of power
for for for classifying
if we then pretend like those were the
predictors we started with those one
hund those 100 cherry picked out of 5
million
they're going to look very good to
cross-validation
so we fooled cross-validation by by
leaving out the first filtering step and
giving it a very uh cherry-picked set of
predictors in the second set
that's interesting
this seems like it's you know it was
done on purpose here but actually in in
some genomic studies um
researchers are faced with you know tens
of thousands of genes maybe and it's
just hard to handle them so they do some
kind of screening in the beginning just
to reduce the number of variables down
to a manageable set
you know and you know and then forget
about it afterwards but that leads to
this kind of bias
right so it's as i say here that this is
i think it's good to understand this by
actually trying this yourself just in r
you've learned some r now you can you
can simulate a situation just like this
where the the true test error is 50
um
and simulate a large number of
predictors and apply cross-validation in
step two and you'll see the error is
actually very low the cv error is low
and as trevor mentioned this is not
something we've made up this is actually
an error which commonly occurs in
genomics and in published papers in high
profile journals
so
we told you the wrong way to do things
we
applying cross-validation in step two
well the right way is to apply
cross-validation to both steps
so this picture
the next few pictures will make this
clear here i've got the wrong way i just
described
so i've got my samples here and my
predictors here
and now
in this in this
first approach
we first select the best set of
predictors based on the correlation with
the outcome that's over here
and we keep these predictors
and throw the rest away
and now in step two
we're going to apply cross validation
what does that mean we divide the data
up into say five parts
we apply our classifier to four parts
and we predict the response in the
leftover part
so again this is this is wrong because
the the filtering step which which
selected these
these predictors has used the
response variable for all the samples
so this is the wrong way to do things
the right way
is as follows we first
we define our folds five folds cross
validation before we do any fitting we
removed
one of the folds all the data for that
fold the predictors and the response
variable
and now we can do whatever we want on
the other four parts we can filter and
fit or however we want
and find when
when when we finished our fitting we
then take the model and we predict the
response for the left out part the key
point being though that we form the
folds before we
filter or do or fit to the data
in order to get a
so that we're applying cross
cross-validation to the entire process
not just the second step
so this is the right way to do it
so in each of the four fifths folds we
might screen off a different set of
predictors each time and we probably
will
and so that variability is going to get
taken into account so this wrong way of
doing cross-validation is not something
that we've made up it's actually it's
actually something which i mentioned is
occurs in a lot of published papers and
i've actually experienced it in a number
of times myself
a few years ago i was a phd oral in
engineering here at stanford
and a lot of people in engineering are
doing statistics as part of their work
this particular student was doing a um
he was trying to predict
heart heart disease from snips snips are
single based changes in the genome
so basically had a classification
problem with
i think about a hundred thousand
predictors and a two two uh class
response
and he had done something very much like
this he had first he had so many
predictors he wanted to filter them so
he he applied a filtering of some sort
to the data set
to reduce the 100 000 predictors i think
down to a thousand and then he fit some
sort of a model to the 1000 predictors
and he got an error error rate of about
35 i think
which doesn't sound that impressive but
for this particular
area was that it was actually quite a
good quite a low error rate right
um
and during the oral he presented this
and i said actually i think there's a
problem with this and i pointed out the
fact that
the point you've just seen that he
actually had filtered the data
and oh sorry i didn't say this this
could be enough detail he had applied
cross validation in the second step so
he had filtered the data down to a
thousand predictors
he applied cross validation and the
cross validation error rate was about 35
and he was quite happy and this was part
of his presentation and i mentioned well
that doesn't look right to me because
you
have done cross-validation wrong the way
i just described
he didn't agree and his supervisor
didn't even agree who also i will not
name the person wasn't me it wasn't you
well the supervisor said well maybe
you're right but you're you're really
being picky you're splitting hairs here
it's not going to make much difference
and i said well i think it might make a
difference you really have to go back
and do it
so a few months later the student
knocked on my door in my office
he did pass because he had other things
in the thesis which were you know which
are reasonable but a few months later he
knocked on my door came to my office
said
i redid the experiment and the error
rate's now 50 percent he was quite you
know quite surprised and a bit upset
but um
basically it was i told you so you know
that that uh with a large number of
predictors if you filter them you've got
to include that in your cross-validation
and if you don't
you can incur a serious uh error in your
cross-validation estimate
so
uh that was again it happens and trevor
and i talk about this a lot and other
people have written papers about this
error but people continue to make this
error in cross-validation so that's a
big heads up and of course another heads
up is not have rob tips
okay
okay so that completes our discussion of
cross validation we we spent quite a bit
of time on that topic because it's a
very important technique for all the
methods we'll see in this course
in the next section we'll talk about a
closely related idea but a different one
called the bootstrap